a veces cuando uno hace demostraciones
largas y en muchos pasos es muy fácil
perder la noción de a dónde queremos
llegar exactamente y queríamos tratar de
probar el teorema de la divergencia y
empezamos por reescribir el flujo a
través de la superficie y también
reescribiendo la integral triple de la
divergencia del campo vectorial y
dijimos bueno si podemos probar que cada
uno de estos suman dos que nos
aparecieron aquí es igual al otro que de
hecho así los marcamos entonces ya
tendríamos demostrado el teorema y dije
que vamos a usar el hecho de que las
regiones de tipo 1 para demostrar esta
equivalencia que es de tipo 2 para
demostrar esta igualdad y que es de tipo
3 para demostrar esta última en
particular vamos a demostrar esta de
aquí y puedes usar exactamente los
mismos argumentos para probar los otros
dos y así el teorema sería cierto
entonces qué fue lo que empezamos a
hacer tomamos la integral sobre la
superficie de la función r por cada
punto n ok y la superficie la partimos
en 3 s1 s2 y s3 y la integral
entre sumandos el detalle aquí es que
cuando tomamos ese 3 nos fijamos que el
vector normal el exterior simplemente no
tiene componentes en la dirección acá
por lo tanto acá punto n se anula esto
se hace cero verdad entonces esto nos lo
limitó a sólo dos sumandos nos tomamos
en el último vídeo el esta integral la
integral sobre ese 2 ok lo llevamos a
una integral doble sobre el dominio de
el dominio de los parámetros ahora
haremos exactamente lo mismo pero con
nuestra superficie ese 1 entonces vamos
a reescribir eso queremos calcular ahora
la integral sobre ese 1 de nuestra
función r que depende de x y z por cada
punto n de ese muy bien entonces como
empezamos pues necesitamos parametrizar
nuestra superficie ese 1 entonces ese 1
estará dado por todos aquellos puntos
que estén dados de la siguiente forma
con una función
aunque depende de nuestros dos
parámetros y cómo es la gráfica de una
función aquí tenemos en ese uno está es
la gráfica de la función vamos a
necesitar que la función esté dada como
x por y massieu en la coordenada j más f
1 de xy en su coordenada k muy bien
entonces esta es la parametrización que
vamos a utilizar y esto es válido para
todos aquellos puntos x que se
encuentren en nuestro dominio de ok
ahora ya con esto dicho ya podemos ver
quiénes nds nds porque bueno esta es la
otra forma de decir de esa flechita
verdad eso es como lo hemos estado
escribiendo en otros vídeos es un vector
normal exterior a la superficie entonces
yo puedo garantizarles que éste es de la
forma la derivada de respecto de y cruz
la derivada de respecto de x
ok y esto multiplicado por una
diferencial de área
esto se puede intuir del caso anterior
que el vector normal apunta hacia arriba
hacia sí si invertimos en el orden de
los vectores pues apuntará hacia abajo
pero bueno vamos a verlo esto en
términos de la regla de la mano derecha
porque si aumentamos en y aumentamos en
esta dirección y si aumentamos en x
aumentamos en esta otra dirección
entonces este va a ser nuestro dedo
índice este va a ser nuestro dedo índice
ok
el dedo el dedo del medio va a estar en
esta dirección que hay más o menos
incluso estoy viendo
mi mano para que pueda salir un poquito
mejor el dibujo aquí va a estar el dedo
índice
en los otros dedos y por lo tanto mi
dedo pulgar apunta hacia abajo ok
entonces esto me estaría diciendo que el
vector normal exterior
en efecto apunta hacia donde estoy
pensando y si está bien orientado esto
ahora como calculamos este producto cruz
bueno es fácil si lo pensamos como el
determinante de una matriz que en el
primer renglón tiene a los vectores
canónicos y jk ok ya que hay que
multiplicar por nuestra diferencial de
área y vemos quién es la derivada de
respecto de y entonces la derivada de x
es 0 la derivada de y es 1 y la derivada
de f 1 hay que ponerlo como la parcial
de f1 respecto de y ahora quién es la
derivada de con respecto de x bueno aquí
va a ser 10 y la parcial de f 1 con
respecto de x vamos a poner aquí
una pequeña separación porque esto
simplemente va a ser bueno hay que
fijarnos que vamos a hacer un producto
punto con el vector k así que no nos
interesa saber qué es lo que tienen en
la dirección y ni tampoco en la
dirección j
ya sabemos que va a ser algo en la
dirección y menos algo en la dirección j
y solo nos falta ver qué es lo que va a
haber en la dirección que entonces
quitamos la columna y el renglón y hay
que sacar el determinante de esta
pequeña matriz que es 0 x 0 0 menos uno
por uno y nos queda menos 1 que
multiplica al vector k por la
diferencial de área entonces
sustituyendo esto ya podemos ver
perfectamente ya podemos ver
perfectamente quién es la integral que
tenemos que calcular porque de gm si voy
a seguir con este
con este color con el el morado que
tenía ok entonces vamos a tener que la
integral la integral va a ser la
integral pero ya no sobre ese uno sino
sobre la región de los parámetros verdad
esto va a ser igual a esta integral de
nuestra función r que depende de x ya
pero aquí la zeta
es la función f 1 evaluado en x
ok y cada punto n bueno acá punto n
si esto es n de ã entonces perdón
esto es nds esto es nds y acá punto nds
es cada punto esto cada punto y se hace
0 apuntó j se hace 0 y simplemente me
queda acá punto acá que es 1 pero con
este menos el menos lo podemos expresar
fuera de la integral y me queda
simplemente diferencial
de área muy bien entonces vamos a
remarcar estos resultados que ya tenemos
tenemos este resultado de aquí y tenemos
este resultado de acá abajo entonces
estos dos son son la expresión de la
integral de superficie que teníamos que
calcular entonces déjenme escribirlo
finalmente tenemos que la integral de
superficie de nuestra función r
es voy a omitir ahorita el x que depende
de que depende simplemente voy a poner
que multiplicaba acá punto n por la
diferencial de superficie ahora lo
pudimos expresar como una integral sobre
la región de los parámetros de verdad
ambos están dados en la en la región d
y en esta parte verde tenemos aire
evaluado en x y f2 entonces tenemos r
evaluado en xy y en f2 de x como ok
esto menos este que obtuvimos verdad
aquí está el menos menos ere de x de f1
de x coma
muy bien y ahora todo esto simplemente
hay que multiplicarlo por nuestra
diferencial de área y ya lo tenemos
acabamos de probar esta igualdad todo lo
que tenemos que probar ahora es que esta
integral esta integral es también
equivalente con esta integral triple que
teníamos aquí arriba la integral triple
sobre la región r de la parcial de r
respecto de z ok y así tendríamos válido
el resultado para el caso de tipo 1 y
con el mismo razonamiento se pueden
demostrar los otros dos casos y estar
tranquilitos de que el teorema de la
divergencia es cierto para regiones
simples y sólidas